[Music]
[Applause]
we touch on college football
occasionally on this program and then we
leave it to the experts to do the Deep
Dives Ross Dellinger of Yahoo sports
their senior writer covering college
football it was a pretty detailed
article that Ross has today and it has
to do with the Pac-12 the future of the
Pac-12 the Big 12 the ACC everybody's
involved in this and Ross joins us on
the program let's let's kind of uh State
the obvious where are we right now with
the Pac-12
well down to uh down to nine teams the
uh the pac-9 and uh I think
one of those teams maybe two and maybe
even three of those teams right as an
invitation to another League
um the Big 12 and those
three schools uh have to make a decision
stay in the Pac-12 and accept the TV
deal that was presented yesterday which
is from Apple and predominantly
streaming or jump to the Big 12 which
which has uh more of a lucrative
probably TV deal with probably better
exposure and visibility on Fox and ESPN
so the ball is in the court mostly of
Dan the Arizona schools Arizona State
and the University of Arizona on uh you
know what what they're gonna do feels
like Utah could be in there in the mix
as well if they leave
then what happens to the Pac-12 10 pack
eight pack six pack it in
yeah they might pack it in yeah if you
lose those three you'll be down to six
teams and I I kind of think there are
probably three options for those six
teams you either reach down and pick two
to four Mountain West teams and Patch
together the league the problem with
that is it's very expensive
um in an exit fees alone again it's 34
million dollars per team from the
Mountain West that they would owe the
Mountain West uh so there's a problem
with that uh the second the second
option would be that uh you know they
each kind of these six teams kind of
each go their own way maybe the door
cracks open in the Big Ten Or ACC for
Washington in Oregon or Cal and Stanford
maybe Oregon State and Washington State
drop down to the Mountain West it makes
a little sense there
uh and then the third option I think is
some kind of merger or partnership
um with those six or seven remaining
teams with say the ACC the ACC and the
Pac-12 have long discussed some kind of
partnership or merger in some way so
there are those possibilities
you brought up that uh Big 12 reached
out to the Pac-12 a year ago and looking
at a merger and the Pac-12 said no and
then fast forward to right now the
Pac-12 reaching out to the Big 12 saying
hey what about that merger
uh why is the Big 12 not interested in
the Pac-12 anymore
well and you know that happened last
year so two years ago when Oklahoma and
Texas left the Big 12. Bob bolski the
then commissioner of the Big 12 College
George cloth for the Pac-12 and yeah
offered some kind of partnership or
merger scheduling Alliance maybe Network
meteorites deal merger and that was that
was two summers ago and Pac-12 said no
and then last year when USC and UCLA
um announced they were leaving George
kalafkov call Bob bullsby and said hey
how about that deal that I turned down
and and uh Bob bullsby in in Brett Your
Mark who was just coming in as
commissioner said uh no thank you and if
someone put it the conversation was uh
very short the Big 12 feels settled I
think last summer they felt settled in
their new environment they got four four
new members coming they arguably have
the best basketball conference in the
country
um they they have a pretty solid brand
from top to bottom Dan arguably you know
they're the the most uh uh kind of equal
uh parody of of any league in the in the
country uh they have their fun football
games to watch I I just think they're
pretty comfortable in their current
condition you know and current situation
which wasn't the case two years ago
right Oklahoma and Texas left and they
were in a full Panic uh but now it's a
lot different Ross Dellinger of Yahoo
sports senior writer covering college
football what's college football look
like in five years
oh man I don't know what college
football looks like in five minutes uh
from now it changes so rapidly
I I'd have to say that the biggest thing
is the athlete compensation issue right
uh nil has come to College athletics and
it is just uh kind of a short-term thing
I feel like it's kind of a temporary
thing one one person in the nil space uh
and for those listening name image and
likeness uh where where athletes can
earn money on endorsements and
commercials but as we turn out are
getting paid by collectives and donors
uh I think it's going to evolve into the
next phase and somebody in the nil space
said to me nil is an era like the
steroid era on baseball they'll be an
asterisk next to all the records and all
the recruiting classes that were done in
the nil era we're moving on to the next
Evolution at some point is that athletes
get direct pay from schools as employees
in some way is it a revenue sharing
split with athletes so that is going to
change college sports right because
every school is not going to pay
directly pay their athletes not gonna
have enough money to pay their leads
their presidents and Academia people
aren't going to want to do this so
that's going to change and there
probably is eventually going to be some
kind of separation of the teams who will
do it and do it at a high level in the
teams who won't but can you see uh an
NFL model here where let's not kid
anybody these are the best teams they're
going to be in uh that they'll schedule
each other you'll be in a division with
these schools and each year you'll be
playing another division in another comp
I mean it just feels like that's where
we're headed where there's the Haves and
the have-nots
sure in the athlete compensation issue I
think will is Expediting that you know I
think we're going to get to a semi
professional for not already at a
semi-professional model what's happening
and what has been happening just at an
expedited rate lately is a consolidation
of the biggest brands in college
football right they've they've been
Consolidated all but for about four or
five of them they've been Consolidated
into two leagues the Big Ten in the SEC
and there's four or five of them still
out there right that are trying to get
in to the Big Ten and SEC trying to get
in the club because I think most would
say that those two leagues are going to
consolidate all the big Brands and kind
of do their own thing eventually down
the line and they're going to be able to
pay right their athletes more and that's
going to be the Gap the Gap that's
already there right Dan is just gonna
widen
you went in on our Notre Dame Big Ten
bet
five years from now Notre Dame will be
dot dot
independent or Big Ten or other
independent independent I I just
actually I spent some time at Notre Dame
last week and uh man they they are uh
they love their independence right and
and every time you talk to somebody at
Notre Dame they they discuss and talk
about their independence and how they
like to be different and they like to be
independent they just got a new athletic
director uh uh or they're transitioning
from Jack's War book to the to the new
at the athletic director and I I don't I
don't think that mentality is Gonna
Change uh so in five years I would say
they will remain independent now in 10
years or in 15 years when we get to the
point and where there there this is this
more professional model
then do they have to get in in some way
and lose the independence maybe so yeah
that's what I think but with the playoff
spots uh they can stay on the outside
and build up enough victories their
Notre Dame that they'll qualify for a
playoff spot but uh it just feels like
you know they're the last holdout here
of would they join why would they join
would they join the Big Ten
um and and it just feels like it's
inevitable even though you're right they
love being Notre Dame stand alone Notre
Dame
well and it's it's all you know it's all
about money right all this we're talking
about is about money if Notre Dame can't
and they're renegotiating soon their new
their TV deal with with NBC and uh if
they can't get enough money comparable
to those big ten schools and SEC schools
so somewhere in the distribution annual
distribution of 60 to 80 million dollars
a year if they can't get that
then right that's what changes Minds is
is money the thing is I think they're
probably gonna get it
Ross great job uh thanks for joining us
yep thank you that's uh Ross Dellinger
yeah Yahoo sports senior college
football writer